I'm thrilled to welcome back to the
program Terry Cogan who's professor of
law at the SJ Quinney College of Law at
the University of Utah uh Terry it's so
great to talk to you you know we've been
following these uh the back-and-forth
catalyzed by a series of three tweets by
President Trump about his intentions to
ban all transgender military service
members from service of any kind and
aside from the reality that the Pentagon
has said hey we don't do things based on
tweets and only when we're actually
directed by the president formally to do
this are we going to start doing it I've
had some serious both legal and
logistical questions about this and sort
of the first one I think might be
interesting to talk about is how do you
go about enforcing such a ban as
proposed by the president well the
question becomes whether in fact one can
adopt formal military policy in three
tweets ah the military the Pentagon the
Joint Chiefs of Staff US Secretary of
Defense mattis seem to be taking the
position that nothing no new policy
change has occurred until the military
gets direct instructions from the White
House there are a few legal experts who
in interesting articles in the last
several days have argued that a tweet
from the president is as forceful as a
formal statement but what is important
is that our military appears at this
point to be sitting back and waiting and
doing nothing to change its policy um
with respect to transgender people
serving in the military until it gets
further direction to the White House I
sort of understand if you're talking
about incoming military service members
you know you you there is a medical exam
that is done and presumably a doctor
could determine if you know and
enlistees genitals don't match the
gender that was selected
sex that was selected on their
application for example but with regard
to the you know two to six thousand
transgender individuals that are already
in the military what practical way would
there be to enforce such a ban and would
that raise any legal questions so let me
step back I'm David and let's make clear
that the traditional vision which is
really the one your adverting to that
transgender people are those who have
undergone sex change operation in fact
is not the current reality correct that
in fact there are some transgender
people previously called transsexuals
who have in fact undergone major surgery
to align their bodies with their gender
identities which are opposite from that
of their birth bodies but there are many
transgender people who choose to deal
with their gender identity in different
ways perhaps with just hormones or some
with no hormones perhaps with just
bodily presentation so the idea that you
can do a medical exam and discover what
it is transgender in fact is not the
case so let's start off with that
secondly and this is the thrust I think
the importance of your question in fact
based on a study done by the Williams
Institute the estimate that the Williams
Institute at UCLA came up with is that
there currently are about 15,000
transgender people working for the
military 6,000 of whom are in active
duty which accords with the number you
came up with which really came from the
RAND Corporation correct and the
question becomes what do you do with all
of these people do you basically kick
them out as a number of people have
pointed out if the quote tremendous
medical cost that the press
and referred to is six to eight million
dollars the cost of replacing 15,000
workers for the military is massively
greater than the six to eight thousand
dollars that it is costing estimated for
transgender medical treatment at the
moment
that's fascinating now do we do we know
Terry what it's considered to cost two
for the full recruitment to active duty
of a service member off the top of my
head I do not what I have a read in the
last days if everyone agrees that the
amount to recruit the cost to reprove
15,000 new people is many multiples you
have the $18.00 got a debt it is costing
for transgender medical treatment
fascinating so that still would also not
answer one of the other really important
legal questions which is that of just
thinking ahead here right just plank
playing this along the to to its
conclusion honorable versus dishonorable
discharge there have been those who say
no no it would definitely be honorable
discharges but that alone is no panacea
during the times of Don't Ask Don't Tell
you could be honorably discharged with a
reason stated like for example
homosexual admission or something like
that and that is still potentially
really problematic for people in seeking
future employment etc so this offhanded
notion that don't worry if we did
identify the people and if the solution
was we say goodbye but it's an honorable
discharge that there's no no need to
worry that that's a great outcome that's
very problematic as well isn't it let me
preface it by saying I am by no means an
expert on military law so this in terms
of the criteria for honorable versus
dishonorable discharge were a bit out of
my realm um
having said that I think that the
repercussions of actually dismissing
15,000 transgender people who are
serving our military is far broader than
just on those 15,000 people arguably in
in contradiction with the suggestions
that the White House was has made that
somehow this is necessary for combat
readiness there is a strong belief that
this would be one of the more
demoralizing things that the
administration could do in terms of
military readiness that the impact on
exists on other non transgender military
people who are in units with transgender
people who are getting along fine right
now
would have a terrible depressing impact
on a military moreover given that our
generation of Millennials those who are
now considering military service are far
more open and accepting of human
diversity the idea that the military
dismisses 15,000 people could have a
terrific killing effect it seems to me
on the ability of the military to
recruit in the future it seems to me
Terry that while there are some who like
to say hey listen the issue of LGBT
rights it's sort of been resolved we had
the Supreme Court decision saying states
can no longer ban same-sex marriage this
is sort of an issue that we've gotten
past it seems like that's a drastic
misunderstanding of reality isn't it I
mean and I'm not talking just about the
dis latest decree from Donald Trump but
the reality that in many states you can
be fired just for your perceived or
actual sexual orientation the increased
use of so-called religious freedom to
justify discrimination against members
of the LGBT community there's still a
long way to go isn't there you were
absolutely right David that the fact
is that at this point it is still highly
contested as a legal matter as to
whether title seven the employment
anti-discrimination law protects LGBT
people from being fired simply for being
LGBT so one has seen this common quote
now that given the current state of the
law and given the Supreme Court's
marriage equality decision in obergefell
you can get married on Saturday night to
someone of the same sex and you can be
fired on Monday morning for having
gotten married on Saturday night so the
law is still very much up in the air
very importantly the Seventh Circuit
Federal Court of Appeals which is out of
Chicago and one of the most important
courts in the country has recently come
out with two very very important
decisions the first of which said that
title seven the anti-discrimination law
does cover discrimination against people
because of sexual orientation and then
in the decision roughly a month ago the
Court determined that under title 9
which is the law that protects students
are in public education I it in
particular it was a case dealing with a
another controversial issue involving
the right of transgender students to use
public restrooms in their schools that
accord with their gender identity the
Seventh Circuit determined that that
discriminating against a transgender
student by not allowing them to use the
restroom that accords with their gender
identity in fact is discrimination under
title 9 a very very important decision
for the transgender community so though
important courts are moving in this
direction
Premium Court has yet to weigh in
directly on this issue so it's very much
up in the air and the fact that there's
marriage equality by no means assures
that there's not employment
discrimination we will continue
following what how altom Utley happens
with this proposed transgender military
ban from President Trump we've been
speaking with Terry Cogan professor of
law as the at the SJ Quinney College of
Law at the University of Utah Terry
always great to talk to you good to talk
to you David